Oh God look at that background thinking
he's scary it's the best carry we're
done with the prologue like a project
what
anyway let's play rebirth let's actually
play nightmare house - you know how I
usually make a montage for machinima I'm
sure that's why most of you are here
that's where I get most of my subs
anyway I get the feeling I have so many
of those moments in just - like 15
minutes of gameplay hen house all ski oh
this is gonna be swear for episode guys
I want to try it I want to see if I can
do it let's do it I'm sure it always was
so hush okay let's see just keeps it he
back again interesting
and comfort to any familiar situation
even us about your nightmare Oh
wake up
it's time for the real nightmare
make cup and smell the ashes
[Music]
this is half-life 2 mod in case you guys
haven't figured it out yet
seems a lot of people like oh we're in a
mental hospital see I totally called
that out
I totally call that oh dude I don't like
how it starts slow actually like I would
start up but same problem
[Music]
came again open Jesus penis this penis a
bad word
now we're gonna cure dear mr. buck down
what please remain calm and wait for
[Music]
nothing creepy going on good
alright flashlight I'll totally take
that good we're making progress
I like it I get this doing we have to go
in here though because otherwise we
wouldn't have found a flashlight oh
that's nice okay let security and there
to be scented lockdown removed but let
me out then you silly
woman hello can you hear me me yes I'm
talking to you oh look if you want to
get out of here they do it exactly as I
say I'll dip the chair I know you have a
lot of questions but for now it's
absolutely vital thing why am i all
wrinkly as you can
first we're gonna need to get you armed
into the cafeteria into the kitchen
you'll find a surprise where either
you'll need it nothing can you even see
me yeah I mean frame good very 16
I get so disoriented whenever I do
there's a seems to be a freaking girl
anyway my freakin background always his
soul
where should I go cafeteria security
alert
patient leaving cell block without this
o clock security and medical staff
proceed to the cell detention area
immediately
milik what
Oh God no problem
thank you every time I say that it's
always problem let's go in here so many
freaking the word Oh God okay we got it
we got the ax Oh bro-heem die die that's
awesome okay I want the hook give it a
hook that was badass okay I guess I
guess oh my god I use you like a
gazillion times
why didn't you react earlier oh I wasn't
supposed to swear [ __ ] I totally swore
I'm sorry you ever bet that I wouldn't I
don't know why the heck you would bet
that I wouldn't swear whatever freaking
grammar oh oh milk
Jesus penises I can see peanuts right
that's totally fine okay bring it cool
okay we got health and a radio talk to
me ah I see you found my hacks I thought
it was how it found its way out here but
you should consider it a blessing you
have no idea how much you're going to
need it for you freaking miss chef who I
hit with an axe like a gazillion times
but still admit nerve
six minutes it honestly it feels like
I'm playing for a freaking life
oh my god okay
it's the puzzle part guys deal with it
an arrow that punched there maybe I
should hump the wall
never works for me
[ __ ] that's only count I told the fish
then now
I know yeah dude if I can soar puzzles
that one no problem
Oh God this is so dark epilepsy what
sorry guys
something is gonna pop up I know it
everytime is really long corridor it is
always bad [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did I just
say I made this what the heck checkpoint
an inspection is required to receive
past this area please remain calm and
await the nearby security status this is
a standard that was
okay so nothing in there that's great
out here did she give me something cuz I
didn't listen I'm sorry guys are they
don't explode but they've told they
explode weird explosion though doesn't
work guess there is something in here
after all what is that oh my Wow
okay let's call my mom mom you need a
pick-me-up
I mean freaking Oh God I don't want to
turn my back against things staff only
staff only they say staff only not
better way definitely No
how many trouble
and eating yeah okay I click everything
nothing happens in case of emergency I'd
say it's a big [ __ ] emergency why did
the door closed let me out are you
picking this up good first allow me to
introduce myself
my name is dr. Romero I mean I don't
suck in this hellhole there's been as a
result wear cut-offs it's just you and I
here in a manner of speaking
I want the elevator doors for you just
keep it oh did I see someone there
[Music]
so why did I live oh you oh you get see
beat stop it laughs look at that beat oh
god okay she won't know this don't turn
it on their faction I you stupid good
good good good
yeah ten minutes I don't
well I could I play too if so say you
might be busy tomorrow yes I am
it's loading so I'm talking to you are
you doing there are you doing everything
all right
[Music]
exposure alright I like should end it
here and I talked to think about sorry
guys
[Music]
you